sometimes she likes to wrap around me
like this and it's a little yeah getting
her out again that's the problem so my
area is bio-inspired robotics and how to
learn from living animals to make robots
that function as well as living animals
because anyone can string a bunch of
servo motors together to make a snake
robot for instance but what makes snakes
so special is how they actually control
their locomotion it's those control
algorithms that we're trying to figure
out that gives them the versatility they
need to move through their habitat we
start by analyzing how they move so we
use motion capture cameras and study
their motion we use instruments to study
the forces we're currently embarking on
a project to understand their muscles
but also a key aspect is going to be
understanding what happens when they
encounter a disturbance if they're
moving through a series of objects and
one of them yields and breaks how does
the snake respond to that disturbance
that gives us insight into what they're
controlling are they controlling force
velocity position how are they handling
this we have a robot that's capable of
three of the four modes of snake
locomotion we're very limited motors are
nowhere near as good as muscle yet in a
variety of ways we can't our snake robot
for instance has 24 servo motors whereas
a real snake she has over 200 vertebrae
in her body and several dozen more in
her tail each of which has 40 different
muscles crossing every single joint yeah
we're still a ways away from replicating
the true elegance of snake locomotion
yeah the snake is arguably the most
famous part of the lab and I'm finally
I'm working on a grant for him but she's
poking through the sideburns
[Laughter]
oh yeah already else for this I really
need to pay them to put more power
outlets in this place yeah by biology
Comparative biomechanics bio robotics
because it goes both ways we can use the
animals to help us understand how to
build better robots but the great thing
about robots is unlike animals robots
will do what you tell them to do every
single time and they'll do the same
thing every single time so it makes it
easy to test hypotheses including sort
of what if hypotheses what if the animal
didn't do the thing that it does to
adjust to a particular environmental
change or what happens would it fail we
don't know because the animal won't do
it but the robot will so because we tell
it to the robot is actually quite simple
it's just a series of dynamics or servo
motors dynamics l/xl 320s so these are
commercially available servos and
dynamics holes they have their own
controller but it's basically a modified
Arduino Arduino based code so on and so
forth so it doesn't even it's not even
that good of an Arduino it's not like a
mega for anything with those parameters
so yeah so this one the snake robot is
performing sidewinding let's give it a
little boost for speed sidewinding is
this strange mode of locomotion used by
a variety of desert snakes and it can
use sidewinding to move on shifting
desert sands does sand is very hard to
move on for a variety of reasons but the
short version is you press it one way it
solidifies like a solid if you press it
another way it yields and flows like a
fluid and predicting which is going to
happen is very difficult
and so snakes have evolved this method
that allows them to move across a huge
range of sand substrates very easily and
it's robust to the different types of
sand they don't have to test for exactly
what the sand is doing so I did some
previous work at Georgia Tech with the
actual saw you onto rattlesnakes and
that's how we came up with the algorithm
for this which is really just two sine
waves they have a vertical horizontal
wave right to left along the body and a
vertical wave you can see how it's
lifted its body clear of the substrate
here so it's got this lifting and
lowering sort of system going on as a
result it can transition to lateral
undulation and then back to side winding
but basically we have a sine wave for
left to right a sine wave for up and
down and they're slightly offset and
that's it the actual code to produce
this is maybe 15 lines and so similarly
for of lateral undulation me fiddle with
the parameters for that one before it
swaps over so snakes can move through
this typical slithering gait and this is
still a pale imitation of the grace and
beauty of real snakes but this is just a
single wave we're working on more
complex implementations and finally it
can even perform something called
concertina locomotion and so once it
gets to that point it'll finish a cycle
so this is what they do inside of a
tunnel if it hit the tunnel wall it
would be detecting that unfortunately I
don't have the tunnel setup at the
moment but basically it stretches its
body forwards like you see here and then
it feels for the wall of the tunnel and
if there was a real tunnel it would
detect that and automatically adjust
itself and then inchworm its way forward
just like the real snake it's actually
not terribly efficient form of
locomotion and that's true for these
guys as well their endurance drops
dramatically when you do this it's sort
of a last resort mode of locomotion so
the only one it's missing so far is
actually a form called rectilinear and
that's actually where they can ripple
their belly scales alone it's a form of
locomotion powered entirely by the skin
and unfortunately we don't have skin
actuators that are good enough for that
yet but we're working on it
so can you say this is a purely
feed-forward mechanism so it does not
yet have external sensors that's another
area that we're working on how to
control this thing so right now the
biggest issue is they're still tethered
because they wind up drawing a
tremendous amount of energy when they I
mean this thing is pulling over an amp
at any given time so it sucks down the
energy pretty fast it's yeah we're a
ways away from fully autonomous snake
BOTS but we're getting there bit by bit
I like to say that snake robots are sort
of where humanoid robots were 20 years
ago and now look at Boston Dynamics and
in fact Boston Dynamics is an excellent
example of this all of those magnificent
robots they're based on the the control
mechanisms observed for human locomotion
so when we walk we use an inverted
pendulum we sort of vault over a stiff
limb and when we run our limb becomes
springy and by controlling those
dynamics that's how Boston Dynamics is
able to make their robots do amazing
things is because they're trying to
control just the center of mass
trajectory and the springiness of the
effective limb which can be multiple
limbs if it's one of their quadrupeds
and then they have sort of secondary
processes I imagine that they handle all
the little sort of details of what joint
gets how many volts and things like that
just like with us it's all handled in
our spinal cord there's a lot of that
stuff where we're walking our brain is
just sending a few signals saying go
roughly this fast in this direction and
the spinal cord takes care of all of
that stuff of which muscle turns on when
and how and responses to a perturbation
like missing a step or something like
that so there's a lot of
decentralization even in humans
absolutely this is just off-the-shelf
servo motors excel 320s
with 3d printed brackets connecting them
but I've built tons of others with
regular high-tech servo
and then you just impose a sign way if
what I basically do is I I say here's a
saw I compute a sine wave and I say
every motor has a certain phase offset
and then I impose a global phase offset
on the sine wave at successive time
intervals and the trick is I sort of
tweak the time interval so that the
motors have enough time to get where
they're going the other thing is dynamic
soles are great because you can daisy
chain them so if I pop this out so it's
not long no longer doing anything so I
can string one input along for six
motors so this is the vertical lead the
horizontal lead for these six you can
technically go more than six but I wind
up having problems with the voltage
drops at the end and the motors aren't
quite doing what they need to you could
see that a little bit at the tail
sometimes the voltage drops a little bit
at the tail normal servo motors it's
just a simple one one thing you can hook
them up in parallel with a lot of
soldering if you want but my personal
favorite for snake robots that aren't
dynamic Souls is actually the links
motion controller links like the animal
and it has 32 servo channels I use
Python because aids a snake name and I
like snakes but also this is what my
predecessor used and so you just send a
serial command that says channel number
13 go to position seven of 750 and take
700 milliseconds to do it and then you
just repeat that send all the commands
in a chain and the robot will go to that
position and then you wait for a little
bit go to the next time step move it to
the next position so on and so forth
these are more sophisticated than
regular servos for all sorts of reasons
but yeah the ultimate endgame for this
is snakes
the whole reason snakes evolved the
whole reason they lost their limbs and
got this elongate body form is to move
through cluttered complex and confined
environments so they're really good at
dealing with those sort of things like
say exploring Mars or a building has
collapsed and you want to find out if
there's people under there or you want
to go sneak into a bad guy's house and
see what they're talking about through
the walls and the cabling and things
like that
that's what snakes are excellent at and
that's why this elongate limbless
body has actually evolved over twenty
four independent times Justin lizards
snakes are merely the most successful of
those there's actually 23 other groups
of limbless lizards plus a bunch of
other times so it's a very very common
strategy and it's always associated with
these cluttered confined environments
which is where Lind robots and things
with more sort of chunky boxy bodies
don't do as well in fact if you or a dog
or an insect runs across a cluttered
field of rocks and logs and debris in
order to not fall down we get slower we
have to slow ourselves down to
accommodate this complexity snakes
actually get faster because when they're
doing that undulating form of locomotion
what they're doing their body is hitting
those obstacles and using them as push
points so they get faster the more
clutter their environment is and so
that's a real advantage and something
that people are keen on capitalizing on
so
we've got this motion capture system and
we're gonna be looking at the arboreal
locomotion of snakes and so the idea is
that we'll take a snake and we'll put
little reflective markers which may be
of sending a video suddenly the
bandwidth becomes actually a bit of a
problem this may not be an issue
depending on the application